[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour un
nouveau numéro de sens public et merci
de votre fidélité vous êtes de plus en
plus nombreuses et nombreux à nous
suivre tous les soirs sur Public Sénat
40% de téléspectateurs en plus par
rapport à la saison dernière évidemment
ça fait plaisir on va continuer de
donner du sens à l'actualité grâce à nos
experts voici le sommaire de ce 26 avril
des solutions concrètes et des actions
qui changent la vie des Français c'est
au avec ce light motif que Elisabeth
borne a présenté aujourd'hui sa feuille
de route jusqu'au 14 juillet cet
objectif des 100 jours défini par
Emmanuel Macron sonne comme un CDD non
renouvelable pour la première ministre
mais peut-elle faire mentir les
pronostics quel est son bilan à Matignon
peut-elle encore se créer un espace
politique différent du en même temps
macroniste on en débat dans une minute
et puis ensuite on regardera ces images
de campagne électorales aux États-Unis
lancé par les républicains juste après
l'annonce de candidature de e Biden ils
imaginent des conséquences
apocalyptiques après sa réaction
on vient de la prendre l'élection
présidentielle 2024 est remportée par
Joe Biden
[Musique]
la Chine envahit Taïwan
les marchés bancaires sont en chute
libre alors que 500 banques régionales
ont mis la clé sous la porte
elles sont plus vrai que nature et
pourtant ces images ont été entièrement
fabriquées en quelques heures par une
intelligence artificielle de la
politique à la guerre en passant par le
marché de l'art les robots bouleverse
nos modèles démocratiques faut-il
suspendre l'utilisation de
l'intelligence artificielle est-ce
encore possible ne ratez pas l'analyse
de nos experts dans trois quarts d'heure
mais d'abord donc on détaille les
principales mesures annoncées par
Elisabeth borne lors de sa conférence de
presse avec Jérôme rallier pour les 100
jours d'apaisement lancés par Emmanuel
Macron le gouvernement a désormais une
feuille de route Elizabeth borne l'a
présenté ce midi à la sortie du Conseil
des ministres avec la volonté de montrer
un gouvernement en action au cours de
ces 100 jours on montre aux français
qu'on entend leur priorité leur
préoccupations et qu'on accélère pour
tourner la page des retraites et faire
adopter des lois le gouvernement mis sur
des majorités au cas par cas cette
feuille de route est une main tend à
toutes les bonnes volontés
avec les parlementaires nous souhaitons
échanger le plus en amont possible sur
chaque projet et bâtir des majorités
avec toutes celles et ceux qui le
souhaitent sans regarder nécessairement
du même côté au programme du Parlement
d'ici l'été plusieurs textes on met une
loi feu de forêt déjà votée au Sénat
serait examiné à l'Assemblée avant un
mois de juin chargé avec un texte
justice un autre sur la sécurité
numérique une proposition de loi sur la
santé et les territoires et enfin la
transformation de Pôle emploi en France
travail d'ici juillet devrait aussi être
examiné un texte sur le partage de la
valeur en entreprise et un autre sur
l'industrie verte en revanche pas de
projet de loi asile et immigration avant
l'été faute d'accord avec les
républiques ça n'est pas le moment de
lancer un débat sur un sujet qui
pourrait diviser le pays
nous allons donc continuer les échanges
pour trouver un chemin autour du projet
de loi et si nous ne pouvons pas trouver
d'accord global nous présenterons en
tout état de cause un texte à l'automne
avec comme seul boussole l'efficacité
une feuille de route qui doit aussi
montrer l'engagement du Gouvernement sur
le front de l'inflation première
préoccupation des Français un premier
bilan sera tiré par le Président de la
République au 14 juillet
Elizabeth borne peut-elle sortir de ce
qui ressemble beaucoup à une impasse
politique on en débat tout de suite avec
leur Salvin bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
directrice générale de cantar publique
Jean garrigue bonsoir bonsoir bienvenue
historien Histoire parlementaire et je
cite votre livre contre Matignon de 58 à
nos jours qui est publié aux éditions
talandiers Bastien François bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
professeur de sciences politiques à
l'université parisien Panthéon Sorbonne
et mélisables ski bonsoir Émilie
spécialistes en communication politique
éditorialiste pour sens publique leur
Salvat on en parlait en coulisses avant
que l'émission démarre il y avait la
volonté d'Elizabeth qui était frappant
c'est d'être comme on peut dire ça au
niveau des Français enfin de répondre
aux préoccupations des Français est-ce
que elle a rempli cet objectif d'après
vous c'est vrai qu'il y avait tous les
ingrédients nécessaires pour une
réconciliation en tout cas avec les
Français il y avait d'abord la
hiérarchie des préoccupations c'est
assez flagrant première préoccupation
des Français elle l'a rappelé
l'inflation le ensuite la santé
l'écologie l'environnement et puis
l'éducation donc vraiment on avait toute
la liste finalement de course quelque
part des des Français on avait aussi un
point sur la méthode c'est à dire sur
comment le gouvernement allait procéder
à partir de maintenant et je pense qu'on
a jamais autant explicité cette méthode
les Français sont en train d'un
changement d'un changement de méthode et
là effectivement donc elle a parlé de sa
méthode à la fois en termes finalement
de compromis d'associations des
différentes parties de main tendue aussi
et pas seulement à droite elle l'a bien
dit elle a dit je tends aussi la main
voilà pas que d'un côté pas d'un côté
seulement et puis aussi l'idée justement
de pouvoir trouver différentes majorités
sur différents textes et enfin le
dernier point c'est vraiment d'être dans
le concret des Français je sais pas
combien de fois le mot concret tangible
résultat efficacité effectivement a été
répété et puis incarner je trouve parce
que effectivement il y avait de nombreux
exemples à la cité de nombreux exemples
d'irritants du quotidien comme comme on
dit peut-être un peu vulgairement mais
voilà donc par exemple en matière
d'éducation nationale quand un prof
n'est pas remplacé le jour même etc
voilà je pense qu'elle a trouvé des
choses très justes pour pouvoir toucher
les Français la question c'est
effectivement est-ce que les Français
l'ont entendu est-ce que ça imprime et
en fait c'est là où j'ai quelques doutes
parce que le comment dire la défiance
est tellement forte seulement
aujourd'hui 21% des Français lui font
encore confiance pour régler les
problèmes de la France seulement 21%
donc c'est vraiment une assise très très
peu solide et puis un premier ministre
après moins d'un an de exactement c'est
le pire résultat pour un premier
ministre effectivement à un an
d'exercice y compris par rapport à Edith
Cresson notamment et Alain Juppé qui
avait atteint des records historiques à
22 et 23% de cotes d'avenir donc
effectivement la question c'est est-ce
que ça va enrhumer je n'en suis pas si
sûr parce qu'en fait je crois que les
Français n'ont pas digéré le passage de
la cette séquence des retraites et là on
va un peu vite sur la suite alors on
comprend la stratégie du gouvernement
mais là on est un petit peu en décalage
avec effectivement les Français Jean
Gary cet objectif d'efficacité on peut
le en tout cas affiché par la première
mise en scène dans cette conférence de
presse cette feuillure on peut le le
lire cet objectif en miroir des
conditions de sa nomination c'est une
première ministre qu'on présente comme
technicienne comme négociatrice comme
justement efficace oui mais le gros
problème c'est que tant donné ce qu'est
aujourd'hui le fonctionnement du couple
exécutif
tout ce que fera tout ce qu'a fait
Elisabeth borne et vu à l'aune de celui
qui décide et pour les Français il est
très clair que toutes les décisions et
que y compris ce programme là est fixé
par Emmanuel Macron contrairement à ce
qu'on a pu voir dans le passé ou
certains premiers ministres entraînaient
dans leur chute le président de la
République c'est le 4 Jean-Marc Ayrault
avec avec François Hollande c'est pour
ça que François Hollande a un moment
s'en est c'en est débarrassé il y avait
d'autres raisons plus profondes mais
c'était c'était c'en était une là
aujourd'hui c'est le contraire c'est on
a l'impression que c'est le président de
la République avec sa manière très
verticale de gérer la crise d'air traite
et même avant qui a entraîné dans dans
sa chute Elizabeth borne et donc tout ce
que fera Elisabeth borne et qu'elle fait
plutôt bien je veux dire que comme vous
l'avez dit elle a bien compris ce qu'il
fallait relancer pour essayer de donner
un nouveau souffle au quinquennat après
cette année qui est un échec il faut il
faut bien le dire elle a elle a compris
ce qu'il fallait faire sauf que tout ce
qu'elle va faire va être mesurée à
l'autre de l'impopularité de du
président de la République Bastien
François est-ce que vous vous êtes dit
en regardant la conférence de presse
Isabelle demande que ça sonnait un peu
comme un discours de de politique
générale un deuxième discours de
politique générale
en fait je suis un petit peu comme
jean-garide derrière ou comme les
Français c'est-à-dire derrière la
première ministre j'ai vu le président
de la République et ce président de la
République il est quand même alors c'est
un président de la cinquième réplique
d'une certaine façon mais d'une certaine
façon il va plus loin aussi c'est une
sorte de monarque tomates c'est-à-dire
que c'est 100 jours il nous promet de
guérir miraculeusement tous les mots de
la France du plus petit au plus grand et
franchement un Français qui regarderait
ça il se dirait ben il est déjà présente
depuis 5 ans là en 100 jours il va
régler et je me suis dit la première
ministre vraiment ça dépendante ça
démonétise par avance la parole de la
première ministre dans un exercice comme
celui-là c'est ce que j'entends dans
votre dans votre explication en tout cas
ça
Élise et bête borne elle n'a pas
d'espace politique à elle pour toute une
série de raisons d'ailleurs lié à sa
trajectoire bon
elle a pas un parti politique n'a pas un
groupe parlementaire c'est pas le vrai
chef de la majorité alors ça c'est un
des effets du quinquennat mais c'est
aussi un effet de sa propre trajectoire
rappelez-vous elle s'est présentée pour
la première fois aux élections de
législatives cet été bon donc c'est une
première ministre qui qui a été choisie
parce qu'elle pouvait des ont coché un
certain nombre de cases comme on dit en
particulier lui en même temps et parce
que c'était une technicienne
effectivement une haut fonctionnaire qui
connaissait bien un certain nombre de
dossiers et en particulier le dossier
écologique donc c'est une première
ministre qui n'a pas d'espace l'espace
c'est celui du président et tout l'enjeu
en réalité c'est la confiance qu'on va
accorder ou pas ou qu'on est encore en
capacité d'accorder au président de la
République parce que cette chose un peu
miraculeuse ce monde
c'est possible que s'il y a ça suppose
un acte de foi sinon ça ne marche pas
bon et là
la foi qui à la fois aujourd'hui
oui de moins en moins de français si
l'on en croit les sondages ça c'est sûr
la thématique des 100 jours elle se
réfère soit à Napoléon au retour de
Napoléon bon il y a eu reconquête mais
ça s'est mal terminé moi je préfère
prendre l'exemple de Franklin Roosevelt
mais Franklin Roosevelt d'abord c'est sa
première élection en 1932 en 2 32 et il
lance les 100 jours en mars 1933 il peut
s'appuyer sur une sorte de d'engouement
et même et très mystique d'ailleurs à
l'époque de la population américaine
pour son surtout sur sonorité et sur une
majorité au Congrès qu'il a qu'il
présure qu'il accélère qu'il peut qu'il
peut modeler à sa guise si vous voulez
et donc là il y a vraiment pendant 100
jours il y a 15 lois omnibus etc c'est
vraiment un travail parlementaire
intense mais et j'ajout à ça la
confiance des de son peuple et ça c'est
capital et je répète une confiance
presque mystique c'est tout le contraire
de la situation de de d'Emmanuel Macron
aujourd'hui ce qui manque audio de
l'exécutif
ce que vous disiez c'est que la
population n'est pas prête à l'entendre
c'est un peu comme quelqu'un qui est un
peu dépressif et vous lui dites non non
mais ça va aller bien allez va sors va
voir des gens rigolent va au restaurant
c'est exactement ce qui se passe là
c'est que on propose plein de choses et
c'est vrai il y a beaucoup de choses qui
sont plutôt de bon sens qui sont plutôt
pragmatiques qui pourraient changer des
choses dans le quotidien des gens mais
il s'en fiche c'est pas ça leur problème
pour l'instant ils sont braqués sur en
attendant
de réformer d'essayer d'améliorer la
vidéo il y a pas une dimension qui
pourrait faire rêver il y a plus de
vision d'ensemble moi je suis d'accord
avec vous genre elle fait très bien ce
qu'elle a fait depuis le début on l'a
pris pour ça une exécutante technocrate
qui a réussi quand même à faire passer
je sais pas combien je crois plus d'une
vingtaine de lois à l'Assemblée ou par
coup projet par projet elle a quand même
fait le job alors c'est vrai que tout
son bilan est entaché à cause de la
réforme des retraites et ce fameux 49-3
qui fait oublier tout ça mais c'est
quand même un très bon petit soldat qui
a bien exécuté qui a fait un peu plus
longtemps qui Édith Cresson on peut s'en
féliciter mais mais là elle y peut rien
finalement les gens ne sont pas prêts
Emmanuel Macron ne lui donne pas carte
blanche pour quelque chose qui serait un
peu au-delà des petits problèmes du
quotidien leur Salvat vous nous l'avez
dit effectivement et on l'a dit les
années ministre première ministre
technicienne pas forcément politique en
tout cas pas de grande expérience
de terrain de campagne électorale est-ce
que ça lui manque ou ça lui a manqué
pour construire une majorité cette
majorité introuvable ou est-ce de toute
façon c'était perdu d'avance oui puis je
pense que ce qui lui a manqué aussi
c'est peut-être un sens politique
c'est-à-dire que quand on va fait de la
politique c'est bien de d'être expert
technicien de ces dossiers etc mais il
faut un peu
alors je voudrais pas je voudrais pas
trivialiser le propos mais un peu quand
même enchanté aussi et emballer le
propos pour pouvoir qu'on comprenne
pourquoi on fait ça et jusqu'où on veut
en fait là dans la forme c'était quoi un
petit peu trop poster c'est vrai qu'on
lui a reproché ça et on lui reproche
même sur le fond je veux dire sur le
fond c'est à dire que y compris Emmanuel
Macron c'est aussi son son problème
c'est qu'on ne sait pas finalement
depuis ce nouveau quinquennat l'objectif
final qu'il poursuit quelle est la
vision de la France qui qu'il a pour
finalement la fin de son quinquennat et
là
Elisabeth borne là aussi il y a une
tentative je veux une France qui permet
d'améliorer la vie des Français bon
quelque part effectivement c'est un
c'est un c'est un objet mais je pense
que c'est c'est pas oui voilà c'est pas
suffisamment porteur en fait aussi
en réalité c'est assez frappant de voir
que on ne connaît pas le nom des
ministres voilà c'est-à-dire qu'il y a
quelques ministres qui font de la
politique à ce moment-là on les connaît
mais la majorité des ministres pour être
ils sont interchangeables ils pourraient
directeur d'administration centrale en
réalité ils font pas de la politique je
sais pas si vous avez vu ça dans
l'interview de d'Emmanuel Macron chez
nos confrères du Parisien Aujourd'hui en
France il y avait une séquence très dur
pour le ministre de la transition
écologique puisque ils avaient demandé à
tous les Français qui étaient là s'ils
connaissaient le nombre et aucun était
capable de citer politique
mais il a des dossiers
ultra important
alors cette difficulté ou cet impasse
politique dont on parle les uns et les
autres évidemment elle s'exprime sur un
texte important en tout cas voulu comme
tel par le gouvernement celui qui
concerne l'immigration la loi
immigration finalement repoussée à
l'automne à minima c'est ce qui a
annoncé la la
c'est sur cette base que nous avons
construit le projet de loi présenté au
Sénat
mais aujourd'hui il n'existe pas de
majorité pour voter un tel texte comme
j'ai pu le vérifier hier en
m'entretenant avec les responsables des
républicains
ils doivent encore dégager une ligne
commune entre le Sénat et l'Assemblée
tenant compte de la nécessité de trouver
une majorité dans chaque assemblée
autour d'un texte nécessairement
équilibré
et j'accueille Audrey beta sur ce
plateau bonsoir Audrey c'est un peu un
symbole cette déclaration d'Elisabeth
borne symbole des difficultés que du
gouvernement a trouvé une ou des
majorité pour faire passer ces textes
oui après la réforme des retraites
c'était le nouveau casse-tête du
gouvernement qui a multiplié les prises
de parole contradictoires sur le sujet
le projet de loi qui était porté par
Gérald Darmanin et Olivier dussott a été
repoussé plusieurs fois jugé trop
clivant notamment après la réforme des
retraites on a ensuite évoqué plusieurs
petits textes un saucissonnage avant que
le chef de l'État ne reprenne la main
pour évoquer un grand texte unique le
gouvernement qui ne semble pas non plus
très certain quand à la manière de le
faire passer Elisabeth borne ne veut
plus de 49,3 Gérald Darmanin lui la
pelle de ses vœux Olivier du soft ne
l'excluait pas il y a encore quelques
jours car le problème c'est ceux qui
pourraient aider à faire passer le texte
les LR en l'occurrence et bien il refuse
certaines mesures emblématiques comme la
régularisation donc pour les métiers dit
en tension on pense notamment à la
restauration ou au bâtiment écouter à ce
sujet Gérard Larcher le président du
Sénat et c'était ce matin
c'est un sujet sur lequel cela nous
sommes défavorables nous nous méfions de
tout ce qui constitut un appel d'air
vous savez une politique migratoire et
c'est la différence
c'est la différence d'ailleurs durant
même temps pour le président de la
République nous pensons qu'il faut une
politique qui régule les flux
migratoires qui soient claires qui soit
ferme qui est une dimension humaine en
même temps qui joue l'intégration et le
co-développement et la première ministre
elle estime également qu'il n'y a pas de
majorité au sein de LR sur ce sujet oui
le thème divise au Sénat divise aussi
entre les sénateurs et les députés et
les républicains ça vient notamment du
fait que le patron DLR Éric Ciotti veut
des quotas de demandeurs d'asile c'est
non pour les sénateurs qui estiment que
la mesure est anticonstitutionnelle et
qu'elle serait censurée alors
Erik sotti a annoncé ce matin une autre
solution écoutez -le
j'ai une solution une proposition il
faut un référendum pour changer de cadre
ça fait des années que nous le réclamons
que je le répète
il faudra un référendum qui modifie
notre Constitution qui modifie nos
engagements
conventionnels notamment la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
parmi qui permet qui autorise le
regroupement familial avec son article 8
et puisqu'on en est aux solutions Thomas
Olivier Marleix il y a quelques heures
le chef DLR a assemblé a annoncé qu'une
proposition de loi immigration serait
bientôt d'épuise pardon à déposer par
les députés et les sénateurs et l'air
mais voilà on a passé quelques coups de
téléphone et certains sénateurs ne sont
pas du tout au courant de cette
proposition donc l'affaire est à suivre
voilà toujours un petit peu de de dos
dans le gaz en tout cas dans les dans
les communications entre l'Assemblée
c'est l'as pas très loin mais je sais
pas vous allez voir quelque chose qui
fait que ça la friture sur la ligne
voilà l'expression que j'étais en train
de d'essayer de trouver
je vais faire un tien référendum sur les
petites parenthèse là-dessus ensuite on
reviendra Elisabeth borne mais alors ça
va référendum sur l'immigration le piège
tendu et peut-être un peu gros quand
même oui puis je sais que c'est qu'on
répond jamais à la question posée par un
référendum donc surtout que la question
justement de du journaliste c'était très
pertinente quelle question on va poser
enfin voilà c'est pour ou contre
l'immigration c'est c'est c'est
compliqué mais d'ailleurs sur
l'immigration alors quelque part ça a
été aussi une des grandes annonces de de
la journée d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire le
projet immigration qui est reporté
jusqu'à cet automne et ce projet là moi
je trouve qu'il avait été à nouveau très
mal embauché on avait l'impression qu'on
répliquait la réforme des retraites
c'est à dire qu'on commençait à annoncer
des mesures encore une fois c'est
technique mais on disait pas pourquoi
quel est le problème en fait qu'est-ce
qu'on veut résoudre en matière
d'immigration c'est c'est quoi les
Français ils disent le problème c'est
l'intégration
on n'a pas parlé du tout d'intégration
donc qu'est-ce qu'on veut résoudre en
fait moi j'ai l'impression que
systématiquement quand ils prennent un
sujet au gouvernement ils ont
certainement un fichier Excel à travers
que les mesures la façon dont ils vont
le réaliser et il manque la colonne
objective poursuivie sens de la
politique publique en fait et ça c'est
quand même un peu embêtant
allez-y sur ce sur ce texte immigration
de Monsieur Ciotti parce que c'est pas
une un référendum sur une loi c'est un
homme qui vise à modifier la
Constitution et les engagements
conventionnels c'est-à-dire les traités
internationaux c'est-à-dire traiter
européen sur cette question là c'est que
ce qui est quand même assez fascinant
c'était le point numéro 1 de programme
de Marine Le Pen à la dernière élection
modifiée la Constitution alors elle
voulait utiliser de l'article 11 bon
voilà mais il y a quelque chose là de
fin qui se joue sur l'alliance des
droites bon et franchement je vois pas
le président de la République tombé dans
ce piège très grossier mais ça indique
quand même ce qui va se jouer là dans
cette période c'est-à-dire peut-être de
façon plus explicite qu'auparavant
le début d'une recomposition à droite
qui d'une certaine façon normalisent le
rassemblement national dès lors que LR
le patron de LR reprend la même
thématique que celle du RN cette
thématique centrale parce qu'il s'agit
pas simplement de faire adopter une loi
attention on est bien en train de dire
qu'on va changer la constitution et
le traité interne le traité européen
alors je repose la même question mais je
la pose à vous j'engage sur le sur
l'impasse
ce texte immigration qui est qui était
un peu un nouvel en même temps puisque
il y avait il était d'ailleurs incarné
par deux ministres et c'était voilà
symboliquement pour les on le voyait bah
voilà il est il est repoussé repoussé
repoussé c'est l'impasse politique du
gouvernement c'est clairement une
impasse c'est le piège des des
républicains en passant moi je suis
partisan de d'une sorte de
réhabilitation de la pratique référendum
notamment d'initiative citoyenne mais
surtout pas sur une thématique comme
celle-là on sait bien à quel dérive
populiste ça peut ça peut mener et
effectivement on voit très bien quel jeu
joue Eric cioti par rapport à ce à ce
projet qui ressemble singulièrement à
celui des rassemblement national c'est
donc un piège pour évidemment pour le
pour Emmanuel Macron et pour Elisabeth
borne mais c'est c'est le piège qui va
accompagner les quatre dernières années
du quinquennat ce piège des républicains
puisque c'est a priori les alliés
potentiels pour faire voter un certain
nombre de lois c'est là qu'il y a
peut-être un peu de grains moudre ce qui
veut dire inflexion à droite de la
macronie une inflexion qui commençait
quand même depuis plus plusieurs années
mais ceux qui veut dire aussi une perte
de substances du côté du centre gauche
ça fait un peu ça fait longtemps qu'il
que cet électorat-là a déserté mais
enfin il y a quelque chose qui est en
contradiction d'abord avec le et à
droite et à gauche c'est ce et à droite
et à gauche qui explique d'ailleurs qui
est pas de colonne vertébrale à ce
projet sur l'immigration pouvait pas
être à la fois pour la réhabilitation
des sans-papiers
et puis en même temps pour des quotas et
pour les
occf etc non on peut pas être à la et à
droite et à gauche sur une thématique de
ce type on peut avoir une approche
rationnelle pragmatique mais pas et à
droite et à gauche et c'est tout le
problème et donc on tombe dans le piège
des républicains c'est à dire d'une
surenchère permanente sur tous les
textes qui vont se poser avec la
nécessité
est pas capable de tenir ses propres
troupes enfin c'est ce qui s'est passé
ils ont bien vu que c'était on ne
pouvait pas s'appuyer sur les
républicains mais puisqu'on veut pas
s'appuyer sur les républicains alors
avec qui est-ce qu'on va pouvoir
effectivement allez cette feuille de
route on y revient on se reconcentre sur
Elisabeth borne un peu fat
caractéristique du en même temps pour
vous puisque un an après le début de ce
deuxième quinquennat oui c'est une
feuille de route un petit peu creuse qui
manque d'ambition et d'élan on le disait
à l'instant pas de différents projets de
loi en perspective et comme on vient de
le dire aussi la loi qui aurait pu être
la plus importante et dont on vient de
parler celle sur l'immigration elle est
renvoyée au calendes grec faute de major
alors vous y voyez les les limites les
premiers signaux des limites du même en
même temps pourquoi alors cette promesse
de 2017 due en même temps elle était
très alléchante elle était très bien
vendue aussi il faut dire par Emmanuel
Macron sur le papier elle marche bien
mais on a l'impression qu'elle se révèle
quand même assez difficile à appliquer
dans la vraie vie voire même décevante
d'ailleurs c'est pas la première fois
sur le sujet de l'immigration que ce
positionnement mais en difficulté le
gouvernement si vous vous souvenez bien
lors du premier quinquennat c'était
d'ailleurs le premier texte de loi la
loi asile et immigration il y avait eu
des disputes des divergences au sein
même de la majorité qui à l'époque était
absolue et le texte avait été
globalement vidé de sa substance pour
réconcilier les uns et les autres et
pour que le texte puisse être voté pour
moi en effet j'y vois les premiers
signes de faiblesse dus en même temps
donc ça remonte en fait au tout début du
premier quinquennat on va on va en
lister quelques autres signes des
limites du même alors plus récent alors
l'épisode est pas encore terminé le
thème de la fin de vie on a quand même
un Emmanuel Macron qui un jour vous les
prendre le modèle de la Belgique qui est
beaucoup plus favorable à l'euthanasie
il revient d'un voyage auprès du pape et
tout d'un coup il se dit ah là là il
faut être peut-être plus prudent ça va
pas tous trop plaire à la droite ça va
être compliqué et on parlait plutôt à ce
moment-là d'une amélioration des soins
palliatifs on va voir ce que ça donne
puisque c'est en cours autre exemple la
police alors là je remonte un peu plus
longtemps mais c'est un mélange Emmanuel
Macron reconnaissait à brut les
violences policières dans ces mots il
avait été immédiat brute oui et de
l'autre côté bah il laisse son ministère
de l'intérieur avec quand même un Gérald
Darmanin assez dur défendre les
policiers coûte que coûte et on voit
dans les manifestations les débordements
qui a eu ça montre cette autre visage et
ce en même temps un peu bizarroïde sur
la laïcité encore le président alors
premier quinquennat avait mis beaucoup
de temps à s'exprimer d'ailleurs sur le
sujet je crois qu'il a mis plus d'un an
et il était assez ambigu sur le sujet il
disait le port du voile dans l'espace
public n'est pas mon affaire en 2019 il
disait même qu'il était impossible il
répondait un journaliste impossible de
reconnaître un bon voile d'un mauvais
voile quand on voit une jeune fille
voilée 2 ans avait avant il avait dit le
voile nous choque car contraire à la
civilité française donc allez comprendre
exactement son positionnement se
positionnement dû en même temps et quand
même un peu difficile à comprendre et
alors du côté des personnalités cette
fois alors la plus récent gouvernement
actuel nomination de papel Ndiaye après
Jean-Michel Blanquer quand même au
ministère de l'Éducation pour les
résultats qu'on connaît ça avait aussi
semer le trouble dans les esprits de
quel côté on est dans ce même temps et
surtout avec un Gérald Darmanin à
l'intérieur dans le même gouvernement
donc résultat toutes ces fragilités
finalement au fil des mois le en même
temps s'est transformé en un mouvement
qui tire un petit peu plus vers la
droite c'est encore plus visible que la
réforme des retraites mais comme c'est
pas totalement assumé la droite elle
souhaite pas forcément y prendre part ou
en tout cas du bout des lèvres et on le
voit bien et de toute façon si le
gouvernement pactise vraiment
officiellement et de manière pérenne
avec la droite au hasard avec les
républicains au moins 40 pour avoir une
majorité ça reviendrait finalement à
définitivement enterré ce beau projet
qui est le en même temps merci beaucoup
Émilie mais quand même Bastien François
il y a le en même temps il a marché sur
certaines gars il y a eu des textes
votés on l'a rappelé tout à l'heure
la logique de la majorité au cas par cas
elle a elle a quand même fonctionné sur
sur plusieurs textes parfois avec une
des alliés à gauche ou parfois à droite
sur peut-être quand même il faut quand
même prendre la mesure de de l'enjeu de
n'importe quel gouvernement du 21e
siècle actuellement c'est à dire que nos
hommes devons inventer des nouvelles
sociétés des nouvelles façons d'habiter
de nous voir de consommer etc
et là on va faire un petit texte sur sur
la forêt on va faire je dis pas que
c'est pas des taxes intéressants mais
par rapport à l'ambition réformatrice et
par rapport à l'urgence des échéances on
est quand même dans quelque chose qui
est de l'ordre de l'immobilisme d'autant
plus que
là vous dites il y a des textes qui ont
été votés c'était avant les retraites
oui bien sûr parce que là là les choses
ont quand même changé et on voit c'est
très clair à l'Assemblée nationale ou au
Sénat il y a eu plein de petits épisodes
où toutes les oppositions se mettent
ensemble pour bloquer le gouvernement
sur toute une série de points donc
franchement la prochaine échéance avec
le groupe yote qui va qui va de nouveau
essayer de contrer la réforme des
retraites en proposant une une 64 donc
la situation elle n'est pas comparer
avec ce qu'on vient de vivre parce que
finalement il y a eu il y a eu du test
ça fait peu de temps qu'on a une
nouvelle Assemblée il y a une période de
test dans cette période il y a eu le
gros moment budgétaire qui prend
beaucoup de temps dans le travail
parlementaire et qui a été réglé à coup
de 49-3 on sort de cette période on va
sur les retraites et en réalité bon et
les seules choses qui se sont un petit
peu fabriquées c'est quand les
parlementaires ont eu
le l'initiative des textes et là il y a
eu effectivement des textes travaillés
etc bon mais c'est quand même sur des
textes qui restent mineurs même si c'est
des questions importantes qui sont
posées et donc franchement en termes de
vie parlementaire je vois mal pour le
moment le coup par coup
les majorités qui changent texte par Tex
voire arctique par article franchement
je n'y crois pas beaucoup alors
évidemment la première ministre elle
n'est pas d'accord avec votre analyse
elle a adressé en partie son bilan lors
de cette conférence de presse en
l'écoute
alors que beaucoup nous prédisaient
l'immobilisme et le blocage le rythme
des réformes n'a pas ralenti
nous sommes parvenus à agir et
rassembler des majorités autour de
sujets majeurs comme le pouvoir d'achat
la décongalisation de l'AAH la
transition énergétique où les moyens de
nos forces de l'ordre
ce que nous disons nous le faisons et
nous continuerons à avancer
là je le rappelle c'est la location aux
adultes handicapées si quel bilan vous
faites de d'Elizabeth borde justement
sur son action législative alors ça va
sur son action législative c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu tout à l'heure a
été très bon soldat en tout cas à la
portée est souvent toute seule enfin
c'est ça qui est très marquant aussi y
compris d'ailleurs quand on regarde
toute la couverture médiatique
d'Elizabeth borne ces dernières semaines
même ces derniers mois elle apparaît
toujours seule au front et en attaque en
position d'attaque en tout cas soit
d'attaque soit de défense mais en tout
cas en faisant assez guerrière et ça je
crois que c'est un tradimage qui la suit
depuis le départ c'est cette solidité
quand même malgré tout à un moment donné
je me souviens il y a encore un an on
voyait quelques signes de fragilité y
compris sur ce plateau là on parlait
peut-être de signes de fragilité en fait
elle a réussi à les dépasser et y
compris à l'Assemblée nationale je pense
aussi qu'il y a une partie de la
population qui considère qu'elle a été
très mal menée y compris justement à
l'Assemblée nationale très mal menée par
par les députés notamment LFI de la
nupesse etc ça les Français ne donnent
pas un blanc saint là-dessus non plus
ils sont pas tout à fait d'accord pour
le désordre et il y a quand même le
respect aussi de l'autorités
tout à l'heure je vais vous entendre
là-dessus est-ce que c'est pour autant
créer un espace politique c'est-à-dire
pour ce on parlait du en même temps pour
sortir un peu de ce en même temps
théorisé et appliqué par Emmanuel Macron
est-ce qu'elle a réussi ça en un an ou
pas non je n'ose pas je pense qu'elle a
consolé au bilan et à l'image du
président et d'ailleurs de toute façon
quand on regarde les courbes de code de
confiance d'Emmanuel Macron et de
Elizabeth borne elles sont vraiment
absolument parallèles c'est voilà donc
là entraîne l'autre effectivement il y a
pas d'existence propre mais qui sait si
dans quelques années elle tirera pas de
tout cela quand même une certaine force
politique en tout cas elle en avait
aucune jusqu'à présent elle est a quand
même battu quelque chose là je pense
Jean Gary est-ce que c'est encore
possible avec le quinquennat pour un
premier ministre de se créer un espace
politique
alors déjà le la
l'accouplement des deux élections la
révision de 2000 ont renforcé cette
notion qui est qui n'est pas inhérente à
la Cinquième République au début de la
5e République qui est que le président
est devient le chef d'une majorité dans
les institutions la 5e République
logiquement le chef de la majorité
parlementaire c'est la première ministre
enfin le Premier ministre ou la première
ministre en l'occurrence alors déjà
saluer ça lui a été enlevé ça elle est
pas véritablement le chef de la majorité
en tout cas aux yeux des Français tout
le monde sait que le chef de la majorité
d'ailleurs c'est il a 28% des Français
qui ont voté pour lui premier tour c'est
c'est Emmanuel Macron et puis dans le
fonctionnement de ces institutions on
voit très bien que Jean Castex Elizabeth
borne ont été choisis pour être des
collaborateurs je reprends l'expression
de de Nicolas Sarkozy à propos de
François Fillon des collaborateurs du
Président de la République comment
voulez-vous vous créer un espace
politique dans ces conditions en partant
c'est un peu Édouard Philippe a fait
alors
Édouard Philippe avait d'abord une autre
personnalité un autre passé politique
que celui de d'Élisabeth band c'est à
dire qu'il était malgré tout
il y a quand même peu de Français qui le
connaissent qu'on ne connaissait on ne
connaissait pas très bien mais vous
voyez bien qu'il a fonctionné de manière
très différente et puis beaucoup de gens
quand même ont été surpris par la
popularité qu'il a su acquérir un moment
de la crise de des gilets jaunes et de
la crise du covid parce que c'était pas
c'était pas gagné mais on voit bien
aussi qu'une personnalité peut s'imposer
dans ce cadre extrêmement stricte et
rigide de la des institutions de la
Cinquième République mais qu'est-ce
qu'on voit en même temps c'est qu'à un
moment donné il a été obligé de partir
je veux dire que à partir du moment et
ça c'est ça c'est vérifié dans toute
l'histoire des rapports du couple
exécutif si à un moment donné justement
vous prenez trop d'espace politique on
vous demande de de partir j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même aussi
bien spécifique à Emmanuel Macron de pas
voir trop de tête qui brillent autour de
lui
Nicolas Sarkozy François Fillon il
l'appelle il l'appelle son collaborateur
franchement moi je suis d'accord que ça
lui servirait beaucoup d'avoir un
fusible mais qui soit plus personnifié
comme Édouard Philippe quand même il y a
eu une partie de la crise covid lui et
ça a beaucoup aidé à dégonfler un petit
peu à des dramatiser à prendre les coups
bon après il est allé très loin puisque
c'était lui le 80 km
je pense que c'est le le fonctionnement
des institutions avec quelqu'un qui
laisse plus de place auprès de la
semaine tous les ministres d'Emmanuel
Macron la façon dont il ne les soutient
pas beaucoup la façon dont il est
squeeze complètement prenons juste
Christophe mais je suis dans vous
parliez il le squizz complètement en
faisant une intervention je sais plus si
c'était sur Tik Tok ou sur Internet et
en balançant toutes les mesures les sur
le RER dans les métropoles à sa place et
il ne en tout cas il ne fait pas en
sorte que ces ministres puissent
s'émanciper parce que je pense qu'il a
quand même peur qu'on lui fasse de
l'ombre il y a un problème je pense que
il y a un problème de casting politique
dans la macronie on le voit bien
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a ils ont il y a
pas les poids lourds il y a et ça ça
rend les choses difficiles parce que
quand par exemple
surtout
il a pris oui il a pris enfin ça fait
deux ou trois ministres sur un
gouvernement et on voit bien qu'il met
un temps énorme à à
constituer ses équipes à remplacer des
ministres parce que c'est pas très
facile il y a pas un énorme vivier sous
Hollande on peut bien sûr le quinquennat
dans tous les cas ça ça a changé les
rapports entre le Président de la
République et le Premier ministre ça a
changé aussi la temporalité du mandat
présidentiel
avant un président de la réplique
pouvait un petit peu gouverner à
distance il avait pas là évidemment ça
change cette temporalité mais ce qui se
passe sous Hollande un manuel Valls
quand il arrive c'est un camp de la
gauche c'est très identifié bon là c'est
vrai que Emmanuel Macron n'a pas dans
dans ce dans son il a pas de Vivier et
quand il va chercher dans le vivier par
exemple quand il prend Monsieur le Maire
alors aujourd'hui c'est un personnage
très connu un ministre très important
mais c'est quelqu'un qui a fait un score
absolument ridicule à la primaire
donc c'est quelqu'un qui pèse très peu
alors il a réussi il a réussi à se
construire une enfin une image etc
aujourd'hui
je rappelle et encore j'ai envie de dire
je regardais hier la cote d'avenir de
François Léotard bon voilà parce
qu'effectivement ben on l'a testé à
l'époque nous la testions et donc je
voyais il avait cumulé à 54% de Français
qui souhaitaient lui voir jouer un rôle
à l'avenir les ministres aujourd'hui
français c'est dingue il y en a pas un
qui arrive à 50 % il n'a même pas un qui
arrive ils ont du mal vraiment à
dépasser même les 20%. donc on parle de
poids lourd effectivement il y a aucun
poids lourd dans le gouvernement
au passage que Elisabeth borne a été
choisi à Matignon par défaut parce que
c'est une autre qu'on avait choisi
c'est pour vous dire à quel point il y a
une fragilité comme ça et effectivement
l'absence de poids lourds mais qui est
inhérente d'une part à la personnalité
de d'Emmanuel Macron ça va dire très
verticale d'interpréter les institutions
mais aussi à un véritable vie politique
parce que il faut voir aussi que
l'inflexion à droite d'Emmanuel Macron
fait que du côté des de la gauche
social-démocrate qui aurait pu
éventuellement être intéressé les poids
lourds n'ont pas justement n'y sont pas
allés et les anciens comme Gérard
Collomb et autres ne voulaient plus y
revenir donc on voit bien ça tient aussi
d'abord à une désertification de du
paysage en fin des élites politiques qui
un vrai problème qui se pose d'ailleurs
dans toutes les familles peut-être moins
au rassemblement national parce qu'au
contraire eux ils sont en train de se
comment dire ça de gros de grossir mais
question de formation des cadres quand
même question
mais ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que ça tient à la fois aux institutions
telles que telles qu'elles sont à la
personnalité de d'Emmanuel Macron et à
cette inflexion à droite il nous reste
cinq minutes je voudrais qu'on parle du
du 49-3 on l'a évoqué rapidement mais
c'est l'une des informations de la
journée quand même dans cette conférence
de presse de d'Élisabeth borne vous vous
en souvenez elle c'était engagée à ne
plus utiliser cet article de la
Constitution en dehors des textes
financiers
ce mini c'était moins clair
je pense qu'on peut pas tout à la fois
nous reprocher l'utilisation du 49-3
donc je confirme que c'est un outil
constitutionnel et donc qu'il est
légitime de l'utiliser et en même temps
nous reprocher de d'avoir l'objectif de
trouver des majorités textes par sexe et
donc une différence entre un objectif et
un engagement vous aviez pris un
engagement aujourd'hui ça devient un
objectif c'est juste pour être clair
là-dessus non mais je vous confirme que
c'est un objectif l'objectif de trouver
des majorités textes par texte Bastien
François on se pose la question aussi de
l'avenir d'Elizabeth borne de ce de ce
seuil à des 100 jours je disais en titre
CDD non renouvelable en tout cas c'est
une expression qu'on entend souvent
est-ce qu'elle pourrait
démissionner avant
pour ne pas avoir utilisé nouveau le
49-3 est-ce que c'est une hypothèse que
vous semble plausible d'abord pour
rendre justice comme Elisabeth borne
elle sait pas engagée pas l'utiliser
elle elle a effectivement dit que
c'était son objectif de plus avoir alors
un rendant lui je sais pas je ne veux
plus avoir l'utiliser c'était ça la
forme donc voilà je suis assez critique
pour quand même lui ok
la sortie du président de la République
expliquant que bah non ça n'engageait
personne en fait ce sont son interview
AFP bon
maintenant je serai à sa place je vois
pas comment elle pourra utiliser
l'article 49-3 je l'article est devenu
autre chose que l'artica en tant que
c'est devenu totalement autre chose
c'est devenu un symbole de de
brutalisation je passais dans une rue
tout à l'heure où j'avais un slogan
peint c'était je te 49-3 quelque chose
bon c'est devenu c'est comme c'est
devenu ça veut dire frapper voilà et
donc
là je pense que ça va être très
compliqué si le réutilise pour quelle
que soit la raison parce que dès qu'on
prononcera le mot 49-3 ça vaudra dire
qu'il y a un souci démocratique même si
c'est utilisé effectivement dans un
cadre parfaitement constitutionnel dans
une situation où à la rigueur on peut
l'imaginer il se justifie là franchement
c'est devenu très difficile de voir que
Elisabeth band se retranche à nouveau
sur la légalité
institutionnelle ils ne comprennent pas
que ce qui s'est passé ce qui s'est joué
dans la crise des retraites c'est
précisément le hiatus entre la légalité
la légitimité institutionnelle et la
légitimité populaire la légitimité des
citoyens vous voyez et c'est très
étonnant de voir que elle fin de ne pas
saisir cette cette différence et ça va
être un obstacle majeur s'il ne le
comprennent pas il y a quand même des
résultats parmi les informations de ce
mercredi le chômage qui continue de
baisser moins 1,2 %
au premier trimestre de cette année leur
Salvat mais les Français n'en font pas
dis à Elisabeth borne d'une certaine
façon est-ce qu'on peut dire ça non
c'est assez étonnant effectivement il y
a un certain scepticisme est-ce que
c'est vraiment le gouvernement qui a
œuvré en ce sens est-ce que c'est
vraiment le bilan des manuels Macron bon
et également de la même chose dans tous
les pays d'Europe enfin voilà ce sont
des arguments qu'on peut entendre il y a
beaucoup de défiance à l'égard de
l'efficacité de l'action politique et
série d'ailleurs elle en a parlé elle a
dit j'ai bien conscience que parfois
vous avez du mal à réaliser finalement
comment se concrétise les actions
politiques qui sont qui sont mises en
place et je crois que c'est ça aussi il
y a une question de de temps et de
rythme c'est à dire qu'entre le moment
où on annonce une politique et le moment
où on en voit les effets effectivement
il y a un temps long et c'est vrai que
très souvent on a du mal ensuite à
comment dire à à
oui à digérer et puis surtout finalement
un capitaliser sur ce qu'on a fait et
puis pouvoir
le chômage ça a été le boulet du
quinquennat Hollande et c'est pas mis au
crédit du du quinquennat Macron c'est ça
qui est intéressant et d'ailleurs
800 jours justement on attendrait des
résultats mais on va pas les avoir on
les aura pas en même temps après et dès
qu'un problème est résolu ben c'est plus
notre préoccupation donc on s'attaque à
la suite ça c'est ça c'est très français
c'est ce qui est arrivé à François
Hollande quand il avait promis de
réduire le chômage les effets ont pas
été tout de suite marquants ils se sont
marqués justement dans le premier
quinquennat de d'Emmanuel Macron et
finalement il n'en a pas été crédité
alors que c'est quand même dans le
quinquiète François Hollande que le
chômage a commencé à reculer est-ce que
est-ce que c'est un effet des waim
komery mais ça c'est un autre débat et
il nous faudrait au moins 45 minutes
pour le trancher merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à notre émission Jean
Garry je rappelle le titre de votre
livre Élisée contre Matignon de 1958 à
nos jours et c'est publié aux éditions
Tallandier